TO GO THROUGH- AND PERHAPS AS
OUR COPIER WILL BE ABLE TO JOIN
US AFTERWARDS SO MY SOUL TO GET
STARTED FOLKS- THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE THE COVE IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY ROOMS AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE OF THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH ALL
MEMBERS PRESENT THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS FOR THAT. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT.
THAT SOCIAL THIS REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE ARE POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TO THESE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. DRUM
ROLL PLEASE HEY 844-291-6364
THAT IS 844-291-6364 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. 654-289-7654
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES SOME WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE IN
ORDER COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE- FOR THE MODERATE TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED IF
YOU'RE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE. IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE ON
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS DISRUPTED
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING CROSSES IN
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES WILL PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS. OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN BE
HEARD BEFORE WE BEGIN. I'D LIKE
TO OFFERS A FEW QUICK COMMENTS
AND ALSO TURN OVER. TO OUR VICE
CHAIR- AFTERWARDS OFFER A FEW
WORDS. FOLKS I'VE IT'S GREAT TO
BE HERE I'M REALLY EXCITED TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU- YOU KNOW
ITS- TAGS. PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY IN MY NECK OF THE
WOODS AND CERTAINLY OF COURSE
FOR ON OUR REGION IN STATE AND
NATIONALLY. AND HAVE A COUPLE
OF INTERESTING FACTOIDS LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU- CALIFORNIA NO
DOUBT IS A LEADING STATE IN THE
ACCEPTOR AND SOME FUN FACTS.
FOR MORE THAN SIXTY CONSECUTIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE
NUMBER ONE AGRICULTURE STATE IN
THE NATION PRODUCING MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED CROPS AND
LIVESTOCK PRODUCTS IN
ACCOUNTING FOR APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY PERCENT. OF THE NATION'S
SUPPLY OF FRUITS VEGETABLES AND
NUTS. CALIFORNIA IS THE
NATION'S LEADER IN AGRICULTURAL
EXPORTS SHIPPING TWENTY ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION WORTH OF
FOOD AND AG COMMODITIES AROUND
THE WORLD IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
FRESNO COUNTY AND I'M CERTAINLY
GOING TO BRAG. FOR THOSE OF US
WHO REPRESENTS- PORTIONS OF
FRESNO COUNTY IS HOME TO ONE
POINT EIGHT EIGHT MILLION ACRES
OF THE WORLD'S MOST PRODUCTIVE
FARMLAND. IN THE FARMERS. READ
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT CROPS CONTRIBUTING
DIRECTLY MORE THAN SEVEN POINT
SEVEN BILLION TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. AND SUPPORTING THE 20%
OF ALL JOBS IN THE FRESNO AREA.
SO CLEARLY- THERE'S A LOT TO BE
THANKFUL FOR MAYBE A LITTLE TO
BOAST ABOUT- BUT AS AS CHAIR
THIS IS MY FIRST OPPORTUNITY.
TO SERVE IN THIS CAPACITY- IF
THERE ARE- TO PICK UPS I ASKED
MY COLLEAGUES BE PATIENT WITH
ME IT'S A LEARNING PROCESS. I
THOUGHT EXACTLY LIKE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS. OR A- HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE ENSURING
COMMITTEES SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND I'M THANKFUL
FOR IT SO WITHOUT LECTURING
OVER TO- THE VICE CHAIR OF
COMMITTEE. THE RETIREMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- GOOD
MORNING COLLEAGUES MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M THRILLED TO
BE A TO GREET YOU TODAY AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND I
WILL BRAG SOME MORE ABOUT AND
YOUR FRESNO COUNTY AND GIVEN
THAT YOU KNOW SOME OF US
REPRESENT. A FRESNO COUNTY OR
PARTS OF FRESNO COUNTY I WANT
TO REALLY EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR REGION NOT
JUST TO OUR REGION NOT JUST TO
FRESNO COUNTY ARE THE
IMPORTANCE OF AGRICULTURE IN
OUR REGION IS AN IMPORTANCE
NATIONWIDE- AND REALLY
WORLDWIDE AS AS- THE CHARGES
MENTIONED WE'VE BEEN NUMBER ONE
FOR SIXTY YEARS AND SUPPLYING-
THE NATION'S FOOD AND X. X. AND
ALSO THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
EXPORTS AND SO WE- WERE VERY
IMPORTANT TO FOOD SECURITY. IN
OUR READ IN THE STATE AND LOCAL
SO. ALEX AND THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE AND I THINK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS- A LOT
OF IMPORTANCE THAT COULD AND WE
HOPE TO- BE SURE AND WITH. WITH
THE ENTIRE STATE THAT DURING
THE SET DURING THE SESSION
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISH. TO YEAH BECAUSE I KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE A TIME UP AT CRUNCH-
AB MISTER SHARE AND THE VICE
YEAR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
BODY I MEAN I GUESS- AS A
SENIOR MEMBER IN THAT I SERVED
IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE LAST
SESSION. WITH THAT MAYBE THE
SENIOR MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M NOT SURE WHERE SENATOR
NIELSEN WHEN YOU NEED HIM- BUT
LISTEN I JUST WANT TO SAY- THAT
I CONCUR WITH ALLTHAT HAS BEEN
SAID ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
AGRICULTURE I HAVE IT IN MY
DISTRICT. THAT MADE MORE THAN
TWO DOZEN- VISITS TO PACKING
HOUSES AND FARMS AND RANCHES
AROUND OUR STATE AND- I A. M.
WE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED AS
SOMEONE FROM REPRESENTS AN
URBAN AREA. I KNOW THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
TRYING TO OVERCOME AND MAKE
SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE HARD
WORKING PEOPLE THAT. THAT BRING
THOSE CROPS TO THE MARKET PLACE
THAT WE SO ENJOY AND APPRECIATE
WITHOUT LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT. THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. AND I THINK--THAT BASED ON THOSE COMMENTS-
OF WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE- AS
WE DISCUSS NOT ONLY THE ISSUES
THAT ARE PRESENTED BEFORE US
BUT THOSE. THAT WE MAY CONSIDER
PUTTING FORWARD ON- FOR
PURPOSES OF DISCUSSION VIA
HEARINGS AND OTHER VENUES. IS
TO ELEVATE THE AWARENESS. OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF AG NOT JUST.
FOR THE REASONS THAT WE'VE
STATED BUT ALSO IN MY OPINION
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY REASONS-
MY BACKGROUND I HAPPENS TO BE
IN THIS AREA BOTH. IN LAW AND-
IN OTHER CAPACITIES. AND I
THINK WHEN WE BEGIN TO
APPRECIATE AND LEARN THE
LESSONS FROM COPA NINETEEN. AND
HOW IMPORTANT OUR WATER IN FOOD
SECURITY IS- THIS TOPIC MATTER
WILL ELEVATE IMPORTANCE
NATURALLY BUT WE CERTAINLY.
WANT TO DRIVE THAT MESSAGE HOME.
ALL RIGHT. ON TODAY'S WE FIVE
BILL IN A DAY THE WERE FOR THE
ONE TWENTY TWO SESSION BEFORE
WE PROCEED WITH THE AGENDA
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER PORGES PRESIDENT.
SENATOR HURTADO. HERE CENTER
CABALLERO. SENATE EGGMAN YOUR
CENTER GLAZER PRESENT WE HAVE A
CAR THE CONSULTANT NOTES A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED THE
FOR SURE BUSINESSES ADOPTION OF
COMMITTEE RULES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE COMMITTEE RULES-
WILL BE ADOPTED IN THE
OBJECTION. OKAY THEN- THE
COMMITTEE RULES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF ONE BILL
FILE ITEM ONE SB TWO NINE TWO
BY SENATOR WILK TO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR CAFIERO. WAS A
COPYRIGHT NO CENTER EGGMAN-
COMPLY CONSULTANT PLEASE CALLTHE ROLL. I'M INTERESTED. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTING
OF ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWO NINE
TWO GORGEOUS. BY PORTICI HER
TADO I FOR TITLE II CABALLERO
HI COPYRIGHT BY EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE.
CURRENT. NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR THAT ITEM
HAVING PASSED- WELCOME CENTER
TAUGHT- YOUR TWO BILLS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. FOUR FIVE THREE AND
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB SEVEN
OH THREE- PLEASE PRESENT- S. B.
FOUR FIVE THREE. FIRST PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THE
COVER NINETEEN- ARE PANDEMIC
HAS TAKEN A TOLL ON
CALIFORNIANS ALMOST FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE TODAY HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES HAS CAUSED A
RECESSION AND DESTABILIZED OUR
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN ALL THE WHILE
INCREASING POVERTY AND FOOD
INSECURITY ACROSS THE STATE AND
NATION. APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
BECOME UNEMPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA
DUE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. OUR STATE SHOULD FOOD
SUPPLIES ONCE AGAIN-
DESTABILIZED- AND THAT IS THE
REASON WHY I'M HERE TODAY IN
INTRODUCING S. B. FOUR FIVE
THIRTY THREE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE JORDAN
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH CENTER AT
CSU FRESNO TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
A ONE HEALTH APPROACH TO BILL
PANDEMIC PREPAREDNESS. AND
HENCE PANDEMIC PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND TO INVESTIGATE AND
TO INVESTIGATE IN CONTROL
OUTBREAKS ACROSS SECTORS. BUT
THE FOCUS BEGINS IN THE
NATION'S LARGEST AGRICULTURAL
REGION. THE COVENANTING
PANDEMIC WAS CAUSED BY ZOONOTIC
DISEASE ONE THAT JUMPS FROM
ANIMALS TO HUMANS THE CDC
ESTIMATES THAT THREE OUT OF
FOUR EMERGING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND PEOPLE COMES FROM
ANIMALS AND SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THEY ARE BECOMING MORE
FREQUENT AND DEADLIER.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE ONE POINT
SIX MILLION UNDISCOVERED
VIRUSES THAT ARE FOUND IN
ANIMALS HALF OF WHICH CAN BE
SPREAD. TO HUMANS FROM ANIMALS.
ONCE AGAIN THIS IS PART OF THE
REASON WHY I AM INTRODUCING S.
B. FOUR FIVE THREE. SB FOUR
FOUR THREE SIX TO CREATE AN
INSTITUTE AND THE STATE'S TOP
AGRICULTURAL REGION THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO FURTHER STUDY BIO
SECURITY AND EMERGING
INFECTIOUS DISEASES. SUPPORTING
A HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE
CALIFORNIA THE STATE MUST MOVE
TO FIND AND IDENTIFY FUTURE
SYNODIC DISEASES A NEW APPROACH
WITH DRASTIC CHANGES IS
REQUIRED TO PREVENT ANY FUTURE
PANDEMIC. STUDYING AND MAPPING
FUTURE DISEASES WHILE IMPROVING
OUR EXISTING DIAGNOSTICS IS ONE
WAY THAT THE STATE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH A NEW APPROACH.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE COUNTRY
WITH ITS INNOVATION AND
TECHNOLOGY AND SHOULD REMAIN ON
THE FOREFRONT OF THIS HEALTH
CARE FIGHT. WHICH STARTS BY
TAKING A SPECIAL LOOK AT GROUND
ZERO. FOR EMERGING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. COLLEAGUES I HAVE
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- RICE BOWL HOT INTRUM
HOW OFFICER FOR THE FRESNO
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER
TOTEM- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MEANS TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED IN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR THE LIMIT WILL BE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF TWO
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION. EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
TESTIFYING ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THAT THE MEASURES. SEVEN HER
DAUGHTER'S LEAD WITNESS IS DR
MOIRA REPRESENTING FRESNO
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. IS DOCTOR WARS ON THE
LINE RIGHT NOW. YEAH IF YOU ARE
DIALED INTO THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL DO THAT THE-
FOR THE TIME. I CURRENTLY DO
NOT SEE THEIR LINE. I'M SORRY
HE SAID AGAIN. MODERATE CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT PLEASE. YES I
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THAT LINE
DIALED IN INCOME. WE LIVE IN A
TOP SEED CLEARANCES. MODERATOR
IS EARN UP TO OPEN UP A POP
LINE TO SEE IF- YOU MIGHT BE A
IN QUEUE THERE. YES IF YOU ARE
DIALED IN. TO THE PHONE LINES-
PLEASE JUST PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AND I CAN OPEN YOUR LINE. ONE
MOMENT.
I STILL DO NOT SEE THAT
LINE DIALED IN. WHAT I'M MORE
OF A SUPPORT FROM TROUBLE
CALLING IN MY HOUSE THAT GOING
TO THE PART AND THEN WE'LL COME
OUT HERE THAT SOUNDS FINE THANK
YOU. FOR LET'S SAY ARE HEAD IN
BEGIN WITH THE WITNESSES HERE
ROOM FOR TWO- THREE. I ANY WITH
SEEING NONE IN WITNESSES IN
ROOM FOUR. WISH TO IN SUPPORT
THE BEST FOUR FIVE THREE. IT'S
OVERFLOWING. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE ON TO WITNESS OF TEST THE
TELECOM ORVIS MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WE
NEED TESTIFY SUPPORT OF US
BEFORE FIVE THREE. THE WOULD BE
OPPORTUNE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR FIVE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN QUEUE.
LINES FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHTS OF THE
MONARCHY PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
IN CALL THE SPORT WITNESS
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JENNIFER ROWE
ON BEHALF OF THE BIOTECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE FOUR
THREE AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THAT MEASURE
FORWARD THE ADDITIONAL RESEARCH
BETTER PREVENT OKAY ORDER. AND
RESPOND YOU DID NOT IT DISEASE
OUTBREAK. THANK YOU MODERATOR
ARE ANY. INDIVIDUALS LINED UP-
IN IN THE QUEUE AS SUPPORTIVE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WITNESS DID JUST CONNECT TO THE
PHONE LINES THERE WE GO ALL
RIGHTS IF YOU COULD PLEASE-
BRING DOCTORS WORRY AND THAT
WOULD BE WONDERFUL FOR TWO
MINUTES. IT WILL YOUR LAWYER
LIGHT IS OPEN- GREAT- GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU TODAY- I ALSO WANT TO
SPEAK- IN STRONG SUPPORT- SB
FOUR FIFTY THREE I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR FURTADO FOR-
PROPOSING AT THIS LEGISLATION-
I AM- AND- PHYSICIAN AND ALSO
THE INTERIM PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER. FOR FRESNO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
I'VE BEEN IN THIS ROLE FOR JUST
OVER A YEAR- AND SO I'VE BEEN-
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. FOR MY
COUNTY AS WELL AS WORKING IN
THE FRONT LINES OF EMERGENCY
MEDICINE- ADD THAT AS AN
EMERGENCY CLINICIAN SO I
UNDERSTAND- VERY ACUTELY- JUST
THE AMOUNT OF- THREATS IN OPERA.
BY THAT PRESENTED BY THE BILL-
WHICH WILL ALLOW US FULLY
INVEST. AND CLARIFY- ANY
FUTURE- DEADLY VIRUSES OR
INFECTIONS BETTER PASSED FROM
ANIMALS TO HUMAN BEINGS- ALSO
KNOWN AS YOUR NOSE THESE. ARE
ESTABLISHING A CENTER OF
RESEARCH AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY FRESNO. AND
REALLY LEVERAGING OUT THE MANY
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND
AGENCIES THAT WE ARE PRIVILEGED
TO HAVE IN OUR REGION- WILL BE
ABLE TO- REALLY ESTABLISH WHAT
I THINK IS A MUCH NEEDED AND
VITAL- RESEARCH- CENTER- THAT'S
RIGHT HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA- AND THAT
WILL SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- AND BE ABLE TO
GIVE OUR SCIENTISTS AND OUR
CLINICIANS. ARE VERY EARLY- AND
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT ANY
FUTURE PANDEMIC THREAT- THAT.
CAN COME ALONG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH R. FOR THE- OF. DOT FOR AN
IN CERTAINLY ONE TO THANK YOU
FOR THE WAR THAT YOU'VE DONE IN
FRESNO. AS YOU CAME IN DURING
THE ON OF THE- IT'S- BY HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTER WILL
NOW FOR THE SAME PER. IN HERE
FROM OP. THE REPAIRS BE NO
LEADER. LISTENER FOR BEFORE
FIVE TH LET'S MOVE ON TO A
WITNESS HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO. SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SEEING A NON ARMS
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WITH A
TESTIFYING. IF ANY IN
OPPOSITION S. B. FOUR FIVE
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
FOUR FIVE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I WANT TO GIVE IT ONE MORE.
SHOT OUT MODERATOR. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN KYOTO
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THEIR
NUMBER. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON- I'M JUST-
CALLING IN AND I'M I'M SURE I'M
NOT SURE I'M ON RIGHT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SB TEN. I THINK
THERE MIGHT BE A
MISUNDERSTANDING WERE ON S. B.
FOUR FIVE THREE SO IF THERE IS
AN ISSUE- I WOULD PROBABLY NEED
TO CONSULT WITH THE OTHER- THE
OTHER CALENDAR I DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE THAT HERE. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
ALL TO OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WERE NOW
GOING TO BRING THIS DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS- MEMBERS DO
WE HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MAKE AHEAD. AREN'T I WANT TO
WORK ON EXTEND APPRECIATION TO
A CENTER TAUTER FOR BRING THIS
ITEM FORWARD- I'M SORRY. NUMBER
NINE I JUST I JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT ON AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN
THAT TIME IS APPROPRIATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHECK YOU. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR THING THIS IS A WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT RESILIENCE MORE
BROADLY I THINK WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT OUR OUR FOOD AND AG
AS IN A IN A FORM OF.
INCREASING OUR RESILIENCE AS
WELL. AND I'M ONLY SORRY I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE A C. ISSUE
INSTRUCTED THAT I COULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE A CENTER JUST LIKE
YOURS BECAUSE WE NEED MORE OF
THEM UP AND DOWN THE VALLEY I
THINK TO REALLY. FOCUS ON THIS
AND HOW WE GO INTO THE NEXT
CENTURY. IN IN CARING FOR OUR
FOOD AND MAKING SURE CALIFORNIA
STAYS ON THE CUTTING EDGE. OF
AGRICULTURE. THE TO THE-
COMMENTS. OF MY TO. WOULD LIKE
TO. BE ADDED. IF IT. MEETS THE
APPROVAL OF THE AUTHOR- IF I
MAY ADD- ASK MOVING FORWARD- IT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL FOR. NOT ONLY-
OTHER MEMBERS OF YOUR- OF THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT FOLKS IN THE
PUBLIC. FOR US TO ALSO
APPRECIATE THE- THE FOLKS THAT
WORK IN THE JORDAN SCHOOL- ON.
IF WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE ON
THE EXPERTISE. AND HOW THEY
WILL BUILD A PROGRAM LIKE THIS.
ALL IN THE IN BUILT UPON A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT THE CENTRAL
PROVIDES. SO SENATOR WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- ABSOLUTELY I MEAN I
THINK THIS IS- SOMETHING THAT
IS NEW OBVIOUSLY TO. A COPPER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN EXPECT FOR ALL.
VERY MUCH STILL LEARNING ON.
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE- THE WAY
THAT WE DO THINGS- AND-
CERTAINLY WILL NEED. THE
EXPERTISE OF MANY- AND ALSO.
INCLUDING KEEPING TRACK OF.
WHAT FUNDS ARE COMING DOWN
FROM. THE THE FEDERAL LEVEL. TO
SUPPORT. THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM
AND- TO MY BED COLLEAGUES AS-
EGGMAN. I THINK THAT THIS. THIS
I MEAN I'D AM. IT'S SOMETHING
NEW THAT HAS REALLY HAD- GOTTEN
A WHOLE LOT OF ATTENTION BUT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY CREATING A
NATIONAL CENTER THERE WAS
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
THE AMERICAN RESCUE A PLAN FOR
THAT FOR THAT NATIONAL CENTER.
AND THE IDEA FROM AT LEAST MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY WANT
TO HAVE THIS SYSTEM THAT'S IN
PLACE THAT THAT- CAN
COMMUNICATE VERY EFFECTIVELY
ACROSS THE NATION SO I DO
EXPECT THAT- WE'LL SEE MORE OF
THIS ACROSS NOT JUST THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT ACROSS THE
STATE ACROSS THE NATION- AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
THIS CONVERSATION AND PROCESS.
ROLLING THANK YOU I RESPECT
LAST FOR NAY VOTE. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE A THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY SEATOR GLAZERS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION CONSULTING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR BORDERS
HI. AND WE'RE JUST I SENT HER
TADO I. CENTER TITLE BY SENATOR
CAFIERO I. SENATE CAREER.
SENATE EGGMAN HI THURSDAY WHEN
I CENTER GLAZER HI SIR GLAZER
BY. ALL RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT
WITH FIVE EYES NO NEED TO PUT
IT ON BECAUSE EVERYONE IS HERE.
ALL RIGHT CENTER TOTO YOUR BACK
UP- WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB SEVEN ZERO THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'D- I'M
HERE TODAY PRESENT SB SEVEN
ZERO THREE WHICH ENSURES THAT
ALL LABORATORIES PROVIDING
SERVICE SPECIFICALLY FOR ANIMAL
DISEASES OF HIGH CONSEQUENCE.
PROVIDE EQUALLY RELIABLE
RESULTS BY LAW AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO CREATE
LABORATORY CERTIFICATION
STANDARDS FOR THESE
LABORATORIES. CALIFORNIA'S
ROBUST LIVESTOCK AND LIVESTOCK
PRODUCT INDUSTRY GENERATES
EIGHT POINT THREE FIVE BILLION
IN ANNUAL INCOME. IN CALIFORNIA
PLUS EMPLOYMENT FOR ONE MILLION
PEOPLE THE V. CURRENTS OF A
FOREIGN ANIMAL DISEASE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS NOT
IMMEDIATELY DETECTED BY
COMPETENT LABORATORY WOULD
pDEVASTATE THE STATE AND
NATIONAL. LIVESTOCK INDUSTRIES
ECONOMICALLY. THERE IS NO
EXISTING STATE LAW THAT
AUTHORIZES OVERSIGHT AND
CERTIFICATION OF LABORATORIES
ANALYZING SAMPLES OBTAINED FROM
CALIFORNIA LIVESTOCK AND
POULTRY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETECTING CONDITIONS THAT WOULD
TRIGGER A- ANIMAL RESPONSE. S.
B. SEVEN ZERO THREE GRAND CITY
CDFA NEW AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH
LABORATORY CERTIFICATION FOR
LABS PROVIDING SERVICES RELATED
TO CDFA IS LIST OF REPORTABLE
CONDITIONS. FOR ANIMALS AND
ANIMAL PRODUCTS OF POULTRY OR
LIVESTOCK SB SEVEN ZERO THREE
MAKES IT UNLAWFUL FOR LAB TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES WITHOUT
CERTIFICATION AND THE LAWS CDFA
TO CHARGE LABS A FEW TO RECOVER
ITS REASONABLE COST TO
IMPLEMENT LABORATORY
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS. I
HAVE RECENTLY AMENDED THE BILL
TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T CAPTURE
LABS IN THIS BILL THAT ARE
ALREADY APPROVED A CERTIFIED OR
ACCREDITED BY THE STATE OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE
THE TYPE OF SERVICES I'VE-
OUTLINED HERE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO I
BELIEVE. WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA POULTRY
FEDERATION BUILT. MODELS AND-
HERE TO SUPPORT THAT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. Q. AS WAS MENTIONED
SEARCH CENTER TAUGHT AS WE
WITNESS IS BILL MATTIS
PRESIDENT OF CAL POULTRY
ASSOCIATION MODERATE CAN YOU
PLEASE GET MISTER MODELS ON THE
COASTLINE. AND THEN BEGIN.
THANK YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. OKAY THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN
BURGESS IN A VICE CHAIRMAN HER
TADO IT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLEASURE TO BE ON
THIS- ALL THIS MORNING AND THE
PORT APPLAUD PLEDGES. IT
PROVIDE THAT LAB DOING IN
CERTAIN DOT. SERVICE WILL BE A
HIGH QUALITY CONTROL AND
SOMETHING THAT ARE YOU JUST IN
MANY LIFE BY- SUPPORT. AN
ANIMAL OWNER DEPEND ACT
LABORATORY RESULTS TO ME ANIMAL
DECISIONS AND WHEN THOSE
DECISIONS RESULT OF THE STATE
OR DO CAN THAT. WERE HOUSE.
REACHING IT TAX ACT NEED EVEN
MORE CRITICAL. YOU MAY NOT KNOW
BUT THE CAL BOTH SEPARATE ALSO
IS HOME TO THE NOW POLLS
IMPROVE PLAN WHICH IS BASED.
AND FEDERAL ORGANISE THAT. ALL
THREE IN A BIGGER SHIP ACROSS
THE LINES INTO THE- ALL WORKS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT NAG. AND IN
THE STATE. AB LABS THAT ARE
THAT WILL MEET IT SORT OF. TO
STAND. ALL KINDS OF AND A
EVERYWHERE AROUND WORLD ADD ME
TO ME- IN THE OF THIS STRONGLY
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO BE FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE HAVE STEP
THIS. HEARING AND OTHERS BUT
USUALLY FONG WITH CDFA THAT
HAVE PUT TOGETHER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
MODEL. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON OUR
AT THIRTY WITNESSES AND- OFF
TWO THREE. C. NONE ANY
WITNESSES ROOM TO FORTY WICHITA
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. ZERO
SEEING- WILL MOVE TO WITNESS
WAITED VIA THE TELL. ORVIS MA
YOU TO PLEASE PROMPT THE END OF
WHICH TO TEST AGAINST OF THIS
SEVEN OH THREE. THIS WOULD BE
THE RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU HE
WISHES AND- OF S. SEP ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ON CRISTINA CARO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THAT THAT MIGHT A LINE
ON BEHALF OF THE JERRY THE TO
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORTER
SB SEVEN OH THREE ACCURATE DATA
VERY VERY HELPFUL TO ALL BUT
THE AG INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- KATIE ALMOND
BRITTLE HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS JASON BRYANT ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN UNITED
DAIRIES IN THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION OR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. MORANT
ARGUMENTS HIM CHECK A ONE ONE
ONE TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN ZERO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHTS. SO I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE ANY OPPOSITION THERE
APPARENTLY IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED FOR SB SEVEN
OH THREE- LET'S MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NONE PUTTING ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY FIVE NO ONE
APPEARS TO BE IN A ROOM AT
TWENTY FORTY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- SO- AB. WITNESSES
VIA TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR
ARE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN ZERO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE I
CURRENTLY HAVE YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING YOU. US FOR LAST
PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION- SB
SEVEN ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LARONDE ANYONE ON THE PUBLIC
LINE OF MODERATOR. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WELL I THINK YOU TO OR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS
INCREASE. BILL ALL RIGHT
ACERTAR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL
THANK YOU ALL RIGH WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ON A COUPLE
YEAR OLD TO MOVE SB. SEVEN ZERO
THREE. WHAT SEROUS THAT YOU'RE
ARE. DAVID COMING IN
DIFFERENTLY AND THERE MIGHT I
THINK I'M MY HAIR. ALL RIGHT
THE BILL HAS BEEN ON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THE JUDICIARY- CONSULTANT CAME
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BARGES HI
PORTICI HER TADO I HER TADO
CABALLERO I CUBBY ARE A EGGMAN.
EIGHT AYE GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE.
ALL RIGHT BILL IS OUT WITH FIVE
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT BILL ON IS
FILE I NUMBER FOR SB FOUR EIGHT
NINE BY SENATOR LAYERED WELCOME
CENTER LAYERED. THE LECTERN IS
YOURS THANK YOU I WAS ABLE TO.
STEP OUT OF THE ROOM AND
TESTIFIED TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND WORKED- BACK- IS
A GOOD- CHURN MEMBERS ARE
PLEASED TO A PERCENT- B. FOR
EIGHTY NINE. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE OUR
STAFF FOR THEIR TIME WORKING ON
THIS A BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. OF THIS BILL SEEKS
TO OFFER GREATER CONSUMER
REPRESENTATION ON THE
AGRICULTURAL PEST CONTROL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF BOARD
MEMBERS REPRESENTING THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. THAT COMMITTEE
ADVISES THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION AND ENSURES THAT
COMPETENT RESPONSIBLE
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES.
SAFE WE PERFORMED PASS CONTROL.
IN MY TIME IN THE US. HI HOW TO
MISS. OF RAPPER A DISTRICT ARE
AS DID- SENATOR COM ARE AT THE
TIME. THAT WAS. ARE THERE ARE
MANY ISSUES AND I AUTHORED AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE WHICH
DID A PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT ON
ANY PAST. OPERATIC CATION
EFFORT THAT MIGHT COME IN FRONT
OF. THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IN A WAY THAT ALL
THAT TOO COULD BE VETTED BEFORE
WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
INCIDENT WITH REGARD TO A PAST.
THAT WAS A LONG THE I. R.
PROCESS I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS SECRETARY
OF NATURAL RESOURCES. AND THE
REAL ISSUE IS THAT THERE BE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AT A GOOD
LEVEL SO THERE'S A PUBLIC BODY
AND TO WHAT. ARE IS GOING TO BE
FACED WITH DOES HAPPEN WHEN
THAT HAPPENS AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT DOUBLES THE
NUMBER OF FROM PUBLIC MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. AND IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE TO BRING
THOSE DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES. ARE
WOULD ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE UPON WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT- WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD WITNESS LISTED IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR EIGHT NINE SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO OR-
SEEING NONE MOVING ON TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ALSO AREN'T
SEEING NONE. OF WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITED FIVE VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WISHING WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB. FOUR
EIGHT NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BUT WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
ACTUALLY THEY JUST REMOVE
THEMSELVES I HAVE NO LINES INTO
AT THIS TIME. BURKE WILL DOUBLE
CHECK TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL- DIDN'T JUST
DISCONNECTED TRY TO CALL BACK
AND CAN YOU ASK AGAIN. I THINK
THEY WERE MOVING YOU WANT TO
GET IN TOUCH OUR CURRENT. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHT NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME OVER TO
ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
MANY LITTLE BROWN ON IN TODAY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS.
PEOPLE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. WE APPRECIATE OF THE
SENATORS AFTER. IN THIS AREA.
HE HAS BEEN A LEADER NEEDS BEEN
SOMEONE THAT WE- WORK CLOSELY
WITH ON ONE OF THESE ISSUES WE
DO THINK. OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE IMPORTANT I
WOULD ALSO THINK THAT. ENHANCE
PARTICIPATION BY PRODUCERS
COULD ALSO BENEFIT PROCESSES
BALK. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
MOVE. AFTER NINE TODAY. THANK
YOU. Q. MOTOR ANY ONE ELSE- ON
THE POP LINE. THANK YOU I NO
FOR COMMENT THANK YOU IT TIME.
MARIN CHECK ONE LAST TIME. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WERE NOT TO
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS FOR
OPPOSITION- THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED FOR SB FOUR
EIGHT NINE- MODERATES MOVED ANY
WITNESSES. OR TO ME PLUS MOVED
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE- SEEING NONE. OVER
TWENTY FORTY. ALSO SEEING NON
IN OPPOSITION SB FOUR EIGHT
NINE- MODERATOR. I DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR EIGHT
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ACTORS TIME. I THINK YOU
ASKED TWICE IN A SUFFICIENT
MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANY- FOLKS
I AM PUBLIC LINE. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHTS. ARE WILL NOT BRING
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS ON
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS. INQUIRIES
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION OF THE
BILL I DO HAVE A- AND THAT WAS
BY SENATOR CAFIERO I SAW THAT.
YOU GET THE HANG OF THIS NOW- I
THINK I JUST WANTED TO ASK- HIM
WE AT THERE SEEMS TO BE A
TREND- NOT JUST WITH THIS
COMMISSIONER THAT BOARD BUT
ACROSS ON THE ENTIRE LANDSCAPE
THAT LEGISLATORS AND COMMUNITY
FOLKS ARE WE SHOULD HAVE MORE
REPRESENTATION PUBLIC
REPRESENTATION ON THESE BOARDS-
IN I KIND OF WANTED TO FIGURE
OUT. SO THIS WOULD GO FROM WHAT
DO YOU SAY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN.
YES AND ONE TO TWO I WANTED TO
PUBLIC MEMBERS ON THE OVERALL
MEMBERSHIP- PUBLIC WOULD STILL
BE OUTVOTED BY ABOUT SIX BUCKS.
OKAY NOW THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO THE HAVE TO HAVE ANY
QUALIFICATIONS AND- EDUCATIONAL
OR PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND TO
BE APPOINTED TO THE PEST
CONTROL BOARD AS A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC NOT CALLED OUT IN IN
THE EXISTING STATURE AND IT'S
NOT CALLED OUT IN THE BILL.
THIS IS ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IS- I DO
WANT. I DO WANT PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION HìNH I ENCOURAGE
IT. I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE A
BACKGROUND THAT IS. APPROPRIATE
FOR. THE COMMISSION OR BOARDS
JURISDICTION- HE HAS THERE BEEN
ANY ISSUE THAT. WE WERE NOT
AWARE OF THAT NECESSITATES THE
EXPANSION FROM ONE TO TWO
PUBLIC MEMBERS YES THERE BEEN
SO MANY DEFERRED PAST ISSUES
FROM AROUND THE STATE WHEN YOU
HAVE A STATE OF ALMOST FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. AND AS YOU SAID
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS THE
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
AMONG THE FIFTY STATES IT'S
HARD TO PICK ONE PERSON FROM
ONE PART OF THE STATE AND BRING
THE FULL. OP BOB PANOPLY OF
WHAT THE ISSUES ARE TO THE
GROUP AND SO. THIS WOULD ALLOW
SOMEBODY FROM. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND MAY BE FROM THE
CENTRAL COAST OR MAYBE FROM
NAPA SONOMA COUNTY DOES WHAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT INTERESTS AND
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS IN
AGRICULTURE TO BRING THAT TO
THIS COMMITTEE. DO YOU CONSIDER
DIVIDING UP ON THE STATE TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE. PERHAPS SOMEONE
FROM THE U. S. RESOURCES
SECRETARY I INHERITED A LOT OF
LAWS LIKE THAT THEY WERE
NIGHTMARES. BECAUSE THERE WERE
GENERALLY. ARE EXCESSIVE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE FROM ONE AREA THAT
WANT TO PARTICIPATE AND NONE
FROM THE OTHER AND YOU WERE
ALWAYS HAMPERED IN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO SO THAT'S.
WHY I THINK THERE'S SOME
FLEXIBILITY. GETTING BACK TO
THAT MY FINAL PATTERN THAT
COMMENT WILL DRAW. FORMER
SECRETARY CA CRAZY BECAUSE HA
HA HA OUR SYSTEM THE OTHER
EVERY BILL WAS ABOUT RESOURCES
SOME HALF HEARTED WEALTH
ARMAMENTS GONNA MAKE A
FRIENDLY- RECOMMENDATION FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER OBVIOUSLY- NOT
HERE NOW BUT MOVE AS THIS
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD. WOULD
YOU CONSIDER. ADDING SOME
INSTRUCTIONAL LANGUAGE THE BILL
THAT- THIS ADDITIONAL POSITION
ARE THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL HAVE
SOME BACKGROUND IN A RELEVANT
FIELD. BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN SOME BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS IS THAT THE MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC- IS COMING IN
FRESH WITHOUT CONTEXT WERE ANY
INSIGHTS INTO THE INDUSTRY OR
COMPLICATIONS THAT CAN BE
BROUGHT ABOUT BY THEIR
DECISIONS- I THINK THAT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT FROM MY STANDPOINT.
I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER THAT.
SO ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION-
BY SENATOR CAFIERO TO MOVE THE
BILL- CENTER WHICH LIKE TO A
CLOSE FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL RIGHT- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED-
BUT FIRST THE MAN IN RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR
CENTER BURGESS HI WE'RE JUST
OUTSIDE HER TADO I'M RETIRED OF
AYE CABALLERO HI. FEBRUARY
EIGHTH. EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
THESE ARE HIGH ARE A BILL OUT
WITH FIVE LINES. THANK YOU MISS
REGULATIONS HELLO FORWARD TO
THE NEXT TO IT OR- OF THIS
BILL. OUR NEXT BILL IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE FOUR
SEVEN OR BY OUR OWN SENATOR
GLAZERS. CENTER GLAZER I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS.
YOU SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT SB FIVE FORTY SEVENTY
TODAY THIS THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
CALIFORNIA A WORLD CLASS
VETERINARY EMERGENCY TEAM. TO
HELP THE STATE PREPARE FOR
DISASTERS AND RESPOND TO THEM
AND THEN THE FIRST THANK- MY
GIANT MIGHT CO AUTHORS. HERE ON
THE PANEL SENATOR PORGES
CABALLERO AND HER TADO AND ALSO
SENATOR DIED NIELSEN AND WILK.
SAVING THE LIVES OF DOMESTIC
ANIMALS AND LIVESTOCK IS A
WORTHY MISSION IN ITSELF. BUT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT MORE THAN
THAT. FIRST RESPONDERS KNOW
THAT PEOPLE WITH ANIMALS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO EVACUATE IN A
DISASTER UNLESS THEY KNOW THAT
THEIR ANIMALS WILL BE SAFE.
THIS PUTS THE RESIDENTS IN
GREATER DANGER. AND MAKES THE
JOB OF FIRST RESPONDERS- EVEN
TOUGHER AS PEOPLE REMAIN BEHIND
FIRE LINES OR OTHERWISE IN
HARM'S WAY. THE STATE'S PROGRAM
FOR EVACUATING AND CARING FOR
ANIMALS IN DISASTERS IS KNOWN
AS CARES AND HAS STRUGGLED FOR
AT LEAST A DECADE. AT TIMES IT
HAS BEEN OVERWHELMED. TO THEIR
CREDIT THE NEWSOME
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CAT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE HAVE ADDED MORE
RESOURCES AND FOCUS TO THE
PROGRAM. IT GAPS STILL REMAIN
TWICE IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD TO CALL ON A
VETERINARY EMERGENCY TEAM FROM
TEXAS A AND M. UNIVERSITY TO
HELP CARE FOR OUR ANIMALS WE'RE
LUCKY TO HAVE THEIR AID BUT
CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD FIELD
ITS OWN MOBILE VETERINARY TEAM
CAPABLE OF RESPONDING ANYWHERE
IN THE STATE. THE UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF VETERINARY MEDICINE
IS KNOWN AND RESPECTED
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. IT'S A
PERFECT PLACE TO HOST SUCH A
TEAM. DURING DISASTERS THIS
TEAM WOULD ROLL OUT WITH MOBILE
CLINICS STAFFED BY
VETERINARIANS AND STUDENTS TO
HELP LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
REQUEST ASSISTANCE. THEIR WORK
WILL BE COORDINATED THROUGH A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH CDFA AND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO ENSURE
THE LINES OF AUTHORITY OR CLEAR.
BETWEEN DISASTERS THE PROGRAM
WILL CONDUCT RESEARCH AND
TRAINING BOTH OF FUTURE VETS.
AND VOLUNTEERS FROM AROUND THE
STATE. THE PROGRAM WOULD ALSO
BE A BOON TO THE SCHOOLS
EXISTING SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM AND WOULD BE
INCORPORATED INTO CURRICULUM
FOCUSED ON EMERGENCY MEDICINE.
MEMBERS AS WE HAVE SEEN
CALIFORNIA IS PRONE TO
DISASTERS THE REASON WILDFIRES
HAVE BEEN CATASTROPHIC AND ARE
GETTING WORSE. BUT CERTAINLY
FLOODS AND EARTHQUAKES ARE ALSO
LIKELY UNFORTUNATELY. LIKELY IN
OUR FUTURE WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREPARE
THIS PROGRAM WILL PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THAT
PREPARATION AND INTERVENTIONAL
RESPONSE. WITH ME TODAY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS THAT
CHRISTIE BALBOA THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. AND
DR J. KERR A VETERINARIAN- FROM
MY DISTRICT WHO HAS VAST
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS TYPE OF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SIR
GLAZER- WILL NOW MOVE ON ANYONE
ONE ON WHICH YOU TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT CENTER GLAZER AS HE
MENTIONS HIS LEAD WITNESSES ARE
CHRISTY BERMAN FROM THE ACT
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. AND DR J. R. CARE
KERR- MISTER WORKING PLEASE
PROCEED FOLLOWED BY DR KERR.
YES MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU AND I
AM CHRISTY BAMA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE THIRTY THOUSAND.
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WE
ARE PLEASED TO BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE RESPONDING TO
NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH AS THE
WILD FIRES WE RECENTLY
EXPERIENCED. OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN FIREFIGHTERS ON THE
SCENE IN THE PRESERVATION OF
HUMAN LIFE- NEED EFFORTS TO
PRESERVE LIFE RATED THROUGH
EVACUATION WARNINGS AND ORDERS
WHICH ARE CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT OUR CREWS CAN CHECK. IF
THEIR EFFORTS ON PROTECTING
PROPERTY AND SUPPRESSING FIRE
RATHER THAN ENGAGING IN
DANGEROUS RESCUE EFFORTS.
HOWEVER WE KNOW. WHAT REDUCE
WILDFIRE THAT SHOWN THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE MUCH LESS
LIKELY TO FOLLOW EVACUATION
ORDERS WHEN THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WELFARE OF THEIR
DOMESTIC AND LYFT ANIMALS AND
LIVESTOCK I'M NOT VERY MUCH
COMPLICATES THE WORK OF
FIREFIGHTERS WHO ARE NOT
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE. LARGE
ANIMALS. WELL SB FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIANS HE'D
EVACUATION ORDERS AND HEAD TO
SAFETY SO THE FIREFIGHTERS CAN
BATTLE THESE BLAZES. ARE WE ASK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU IS BOWMAN MOTOR
CABLING PLEASE BRING UP- DR JAY
KERR. THANK YOU MISTER FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY THANK YOU- I
HAVE BEEN A YOU KNOW BETTER AND
BAY AREA FOR THE LAST THIRTY
PLUS YEARS AND FOR THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS I'VE BEEN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COORDINATOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL RESERVE CORPS. AND THE
MISSION OF OUR GROUP IS TO
PROVIDE BETTER CARE FOR ANIMALS
IMPACTED BY DISASTERS IN THAT
CAPACITY I HAVE DEPLOYED TO
MULTIPLE WILDFIRES IN FOUR
DIFFERENT COUNTIES I CAN ATTEST
THAT RECENT INCIDENTS.
INCIDENTS AND INCLUDING THE
CAMPAIGN TO COUNTY HAVE THE
MARKEDLY ELEVATED THE NEED FOR
DISASTER PLANNING IT INCLUDES
OUR PETS LIVESTOCK AND I WOULD
ADD. LIKE THIS WELL. BUT THE
CITY OKAY IS KERN CHARGED THE
DEATH RESPONSE FOR ANIMAL AND
CYNICAL POINTED OUT- YOUR PER%
STATURE PLANNING I AND I AM.
THEIR AT- BUT FRANKLY THERE THE
RESOURCE OR ARE LIMITED. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE- OF THE
PEOPLE WAS WORLD FROM. AND THE
STATE ABILITY TO PREPARE FOR
DESSERT. CAL ANIMALS IN
EMERGENCIES- THIS NEW
VETERINARY EMERGENCY TEAM WILL
HELP CDSA CALIFORNIA.
PREPARATION MITIGATION RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY FOR ANY FUTURE
DISASTERS. I'M ALSO PLEASED TO
SEE THAT THE BILL'S ALREADY
RECEIVED A SUPPORT POSITION
FROM. CDMA JUST LIKE A QUICK.
I'M SURPRISED HE ON BOARD A OUR
LOCAL FIRE JUST. I WERE CLOSE
WITH ON A NEW MACHINE AND SO
NOT TO SEE THAT THE- CPI AS-
ALREADY TAKE IN SUPPORT
POSITION. AT THE POINT ABOUT
ALREADY- KNOW- THE DISASTER
RESPONSE INCLUDE ANIMALS
BECAUSE EXT HAS SHOWN THAT MANY
PEOPLE. AND I WOULD HAVE MANY
PEOPLE PUT THEMSELVES. AN
APPROACH PURCHASED BOTTLES OF
RISK THEIR ANIMAL ARE NOT TO
CORE- A YES VOTE ON S. B. FOUR.
ONE BENEFIT CITIZENS AND PANAMA
OKAY. AND I TO YOU FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU DR- LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE- SEEING NON MOVING
OVER TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
SEEING NO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR
SEVEN. LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR.
I CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. HERE FIVE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FIVE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ON
CRISTINA DECARO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION CDMA IS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR SEVEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MATER
CAN YOU ASK AGAIN IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING HER
FIRST FROM SUPPORT WITNESSES-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO-
THOSE THAT MAY BE AN
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED FOR SB FIVE
FOUR SEVEN. MOVING ON TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OF THREE- SEEING NONE
MOVING OVER TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ALSO SEEING NONE- MATER
CAN YOU CHECK YOUR CONFERENCE
LINE FOR THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. FIVE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR I APPRECIATED- THANK
YOU OUT TO ALL THE- OF THE
FOLKS WHO CALLED IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ARE WE GONNA BRING
THIS DISCUSSION BACK- TO OUR
MEMBERS- IF I MAY I TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR OF FOR
THIS BILL I THINK IT IS A
FANTASTIC IDEA- HAVING
REPRESENTED- THE TERRITORY THAT
EXPERIENCED- THE CREEK FIRE-
WHICH IS THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND ACRES.
AND THEIR FIRES AND NATURAL
DISASTERS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THE IDEA THAT WE COULD HELP
DEAL WITH ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ELEMENT WHILE ALSO LOOKING
AFTER- OF THE LIVESTOCK AND
ANIMALS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM I
THINK IS A VERY SMART. AND VERY
EFFECTIVE WAY- CAN YOU COMMENT-
ON I KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE IS THERE IS A AN
ORGANIZATION THAT DOES PROVIDE.
A SERVICE LIKE THIS BUT THE
FORMALITY THAT YOUR BRING TO
THIS PROGRAM WITH ELEVATE THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY CAN COMMENT ON
THAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE PROGRAMS AND
VOLUNTEERS WHO DO WORK IN THIS
ISSUE AND ON THIS AREA. OTHER
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL PEOPLE- BUT
THEY'RE JUST VOLUNTEERS AND
THERE'S NO PROFESSIONALISM AND
THERE'S NO- A STEADY-
LEADERSHIP THAT I THINK THAT WE
NEED AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME
AGAIN I THANK ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS IS
VOLUNTEERS AND SUPPORTERS BUT-
WE NEED EXPERTISE WE NEED
COORDINATION BEFORE THE
DISASTER HAPPENS AT AT WE HAVE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE THAT ARE
WILLING TO HELP IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE DISASTER BUT WE NEED
THAT PREPARATION TO DO OUR BEST
WORK AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
INTENDS TO TRY TO TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH. IF YOU COULD ATTACH
ME AS A SUPPORT ARM AUTHORIZED
BY TO APPRECIATE THAT MOVING ON
TO OUR COLLEAGUES ON. FOLKS
WISHING TO COMMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER JERRY. I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THIS MOMENT.
AS A AS A PET OWNER AND SOMEONE
WHO'S A WHO'S LOST PROPERTY IN
IN THE CREEK FIRE- THIS IS A OF
A FANTASTIC THING AND I KNOW.
MY IN LAWS LIVE UP IN YOUR AREA
HAVE HAD TO HAVE HAD. EVACUATE
MULTIPLE TIMES FOR MULTIPLE
REASONS A LOT OF UMBRELLA AND
FIRE AND GETTING THE ANIMAL
SAFE IS ALWAYS THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. I THANK YOU FOR THIS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR- OF. THE SICK OF YOUR
WORK- ALL RIGHT THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION- KENTUCKY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CENTER BARGES FIVE
LARGEST HIGH HER TADO BY THE
TIME I CABALLERO AYE KABIR AYE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE. BILLS OUT WITH FIVE
HONEST I CLOSED DOWN- THE VOTE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT I SKIPPED
ON THE CLOTHES. ALL RIGHT WELL
FOLKS I BELIEVE THAT COMPLETES
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT WE CAN
REOPEN IF WE'D LIKE- CENTER
GLAZER TO HAVE A CLOSING
STATEMENT- THERE KNOW WHAT
BILLS ON CALL SO THERE'S NO
NEED TO LIFT THEM- ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU A FIVE TWO OR THE END
OF WHO PER. IN PUBLIC TEN TODAY
IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR CONCERNS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
AG COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US. I WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION- WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
IS NOW ADJOURNED. AND THANK. IF.